hey this is presh talwalkar
baseball is a game of traditions and
rules
rule 2.02 of the mlb handbook carefully
defines home plate
by the following geometric construction
the home base is defined as a square
where one side is 17 inches
two corners are removed
the two adjacent sides measure eight and
a half inches and the remaining two
sides measure 12 inches and meet at a
right angle
there's only one problem with this very
carefully defined construction
it's an impossible shape mathematically
this creates an interesting geometric
little puzzle
if we were to say the dimensions of 17
inches
and eight and a half inches as well as
the following right angles are correct
what would be the correct measure of the
remaining sides
that is
can you solve for the correct value of x
to make home plate
geometrically possible
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so how can we solve for the correct
value of x
we'll divide the shape into two
different shapes we'll draw a line
connecting the two sides of eight and a
half inches
this creates an upper rectangle and a
lower isosceles right triangle
because the upper shape is a rectangle
we know that this length will be 17
inches
now we can focus on the isosceles right
triangle
by the pythagorean theorem
x squared plus x squared is equal to 17
squared
this means 2x squared is equal to 17
squared which means x squared is equal
to 17 squared divided by 2 and so
x is equal to 17 divided by the square
root of 2 which is approximately
12.02
which is slightly larger than the 12
inches that's defined in the handbook
if mlb wanted to be mathematically
correct it could say in the next
iteration of its handbook that the two
remaining sides should measure about 12
inches
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description